good morning millennials
you know when you're like get it
together stuck in a stair
in a city you don't know no like when
you're staring and like you can't stop
um do you have any idea what i'm talking
about like i think so but i wouldn't
feel that way right now when we
have such an exciting friday show for
you guys we're sitting here
we're friday friday
gotta get down on friday we're sitting
here in blankets if you're watching on
youtube
because it's so cold outside but our
building has like such strong ac which
when it's hot outside it
it makes it light it makes it still a
little cold but fine but with the cold
outside we're
freezing in here so even though like i
totally got all dressed up for the show
today
like jeans and everything um it's a
blanket sort of day
we're just like so small and fell in
cold we're seeing so
cold and small oh we're just like
shivering because we're so
lit up um question for you that i asked
you earlier and i didn't get a straight
answer are you hungover today
yes i thought i made that explicitly i
thought we hadn't spoken
i saw your instagram story of some empty
glasses
yeah they were shh alcoholic beverages
you were consuming alcoholic beverages
were you
don't tell my mom but i was and i had a
good time and you know what
i'd do it again so what'd you do last
night let me tell you because i have a
great story for you
great i love a great story with my
friend jason for me
i want to know my friends two nights in
a row with abe yes must be confusing
jason and abe are the same person jason
abramson everyone calls him abe like
never called him jason in my life like
if somebody
like said jason i'd be like whoa yeah so
we had a lovely time and we drank
and then taylor strecker called me she
was like out and she wanted to go to
maurice crisis but like she didn't have
anyone to go with so i was like of
course i will come
you know what maurice crisis is right
yes so i haven't been since before the
pandemic
and literally there was a moment where
you can't film but like i was dying to
because i was like you needed to see
this
so like every now and then you know like
a star comes in and
i can't even okay and last night first
of all you know who was there remember
skye from the politician mm-hmm
she like ran against yeah yeah in high
school
she was there yeah just that was like an
anecdote
and um i guess there were like some
off-broadway broadway people there
because usually like everyone's just
chilling and singing
but they had like a full-blown
performance where people from different
parts of the bar just like came they had
this arrangement of
when the sharpest words want to cut me
down and then there was all these
harmonies
and the crowd we were all only supposed
to say
oh and then like the singers were really
singing but we were all just like
oh oh my god it was like camp toast like
it was
so fun and it was like right when i got
there just like stumbled in
it was so fun but the only pro my only
problem with that place is like
for me at least it seemed like when i do
karaoke like the amount of fun i have is
depending on whether or not i know the
songs
and last time i feel like it was a
really kind of off-broadway kind of
night or like
deep not about like deep broadway people
who like know so many
but that's what i think that's what i
associate with maurice crisis like
broadway
yeah of course but like i when i say
brother i don't think you're enough of a
broadway film
to luxurious crisis all the time 100
like
so many songs from little shop of
horrors like i saw that play once a
million years ago
so many songs from musicals i had
literally never heard of um
and i requested three songs one of them
got played which was
fabulous everyone's like waving through
a window okay defying gravity
and she used to be mine from waitress
that's a little [ __ ] depressing
by the way the place that song is so sad
no no but see maurice can't be brought
down by like a song like
everyone just gets excited like about
the song you know i know but like
that seems really like a low song and by
the way i don't know if you've watched
younger in a while but they went
to maurice crisis on younger i didn't
watch younger i think it was this season
or maybe last also the series finale
of younger aired this week i have not
seen it i have not seen it either
no well i'm glad that you had fun i did
it was so nice to see taylor strecker
and so nice to be back in maurice crisis
like
if you go it's cash only i wish somebody
had reminded me of that before i left
the house
yeah also like have cash on you
generally speaking you usually need it
for the most part i
always do i've that's something that
i've
started doing like with age like and
i've been doing for the last few
years and you just sometimes you need
cash and it's good to have it you don't
want to be like oh i don't have cash
sorry
be that person like you want a tip or
something just like carry cash with you
yeah ever get a bigger wallet ever since
i started gambling
i pretty much always have cash that's
good yeah it's really good
that's why i gamble that's why you have
cash no because you gamble
no and i gamble because i need cash
because you have cash
yeah um so that's what i did what did
you do i had an
early evening with brew i was so tired
yesterday so
i was just like ready for the
kardashians finale and then i really
wanted to power read my book because
it's taking me too long to finish and i
need to just get through it so i got to
like 75
so hopefully i'll finish it tonight but
it's just taking me way too long and i'm
really excited to
switch gears after i read this book
because it's just i need to switch gears
gears are meant to be switched yes so
two very different evenings but i did
watch the kardashians this morning
oh nice i know it was some of the worst
episode i've ever seen
what it was so goddamn boring well
that's crazy because like
maybe you watched like half i've been
fully invested
no so i watched this morning and
honestly like i was about to say like i
was more invested
and more enthralled and i got choked up
but at the time
maybe because you were like hungover
drunk yeah like i always cry when i'm
hungover either from laughing or being
sad
yeah your emotions are just heightened
yeah like i literally saw this clip of
wheel of fortune from last night like 10
minutes ago and i almost cried it was
the funniest thing i've ever seen in my
life yeah so that's a good way to watch
kardashians i was just like
i think the season ended the way it's
been going for a while which was just
long and drawn out
there were some interesting
conversations but there were also such
dumb ones like kendall and kylie sitting
there to talk about
how the show ending makes them feel and
it's like you could just like the chris
is behind the camera with the gun
yeah making them have this conversation
hundreds like we don't know what it's
like to not have the show like i don't
what about the last seven years of your
life
you guys don't even do the show so like
shut up yeah
it was just it felt really silly
obviously i was glad for that kim and
chris conversation which was
so honest or at least as honestly as
we're gonna get from here
no i know no this is just the um the
foreplay for it
like i haven't even gotten into right
now because we'll get into the
conversation
just talking about the conversation yeah
and so yeah that was really
my evening brew is doing so well i know
everyone feeling well
feeling well being well he's just so
funny he's always cracking me up
and i know everyone always wants a
little brew update so update
that's what's new with brew and that's
what you missed
on bro
and theo's here and honestly i've been
having like a renaissance with theo
these last couple days i'm [ __ ]
obsessed with him good as you should be
are you gonna give him your breast milk
oh you want a little breast milk come
here
no get the camera over the camera
you want some breast milk my tea who's
my little tiki boy
i love you so you hungry okay it's safe
to watch oh look he knows the word
hungry he's like oh god
he's like i'm [ __ ] two breakfast tigs
two
two breakfast tits breast milk
i don't even know what i'm saying like
no i think that um
it's just one of those days you know i
think this pimple on my cranium has
officially gone to my head
because of your brain okay over the last
few days and jackie's like really the
only one who could see it because it's
on this side of my face thank you god
everyone to see it like do you want to
just turn
no i'm not proud of it okay um it's been
growing and growing like
obviously it has planted roots in my
skin like it's deep and
big and monstrous but it hasn't come to
a head yet
so i've been trying to be patient to
wait to pop it but of course like last
night i just
sat in front of my mirror and went at it
with my fingers and this like tool kit
set that i got from amazon it has like a
little scalpel
so i made like a little hole and then
has all these extractors
and now the pimple of course didn't pop
first of all
and second of all is three times bigger
three times brighter
three times redder three times stronger
and jackie's the one who's forced to
look at it it's in a pretty good spot
for a picture and also your mic
stand is kind of blocking it for me good
yeah also
i just wish you hadn't done all those
things of course but it's so much worse
and you and you think i'd learn my
lesson but i literally guarantee you
next time this happens
no you live for popping pimps i think
you like getting them so you can pop
them i wish that i would have waited
because it would have been such a good
pimple to pop
but like i literally couldn't it was
like it's been three days already you
know what they say good things come to
those who wait and that's not you
and girls who don't wait get scars on
their face and that's literally me
yeah damn i'm sorry very upsetting well
i think without further a
did it do so we can release you i feel
like the teacher and this is the
classroom and you know the sooner we get
into today's lesson the sooner you guys
can head out to your fabulous weekend so
without further ado
where are you right here so cute love
him love to see it here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by the
zebra think about all the quarantine
purchases you made late night pizza
deliveries the online trainer you
ghosted
then there's one of your biggest
purchases of the year insurance
that's funny that is funny americans
overspend on car and home insurance by
billions every year and that's money
that can be spent on more retail therapy
or more trainers you'll never see again
that's where the zebra can help the
zebra is the nation's leading insurance
comparison site for car
and home insurance in minutes you can
complete policies from every major
provider for free
all on one independent marketplace after
a few questions the zebra pairs people
with the right insurance company for
them
helping everyone save time and money
make insurance your smartest purchase
yet
visit the zebra.com toast to get your
free quote today
visit the zebra.com toast are you okay
i don't know why i'm like having
uncontrollable laughter but i'm okay
it is something in particular making you
laugh it's like something in my brain
like i don't want to share
is he your pimple are you ready no is it
my pimple for you
i can't even see it you're the one
talking about anyone who brought it up i
just referenced a joke like
so much of joking is referencing
previous things to reference or not
reference throw up put it in a blender i
chose to reference and now i regret it
first story big bad bad news literally
it's a big bad bad
bounce chris lane and lauren bushnellian
welcome baby
son dutton walker in into their lives
what a weird
headline walker lane is a country star
dutton walker lane
is the biggest country star of all time
actually
yeah selling out stadiums already um the
kid was nine pounds lauren lane is
literally the smallest person ever like
i don't know how she gave birth to a
nine pound watermelon
but we'd love to see it we'd love to see
it i'm so happy for like i could do a
whole analysis
on how her journey after the bachelor is
like so stunning in so many ways
but i won't but i could back to being
cold um no i totally agree i feel like
also and i'm sure she felt this way more
than anyone she felt like she was
pregnant for so long
yeah and i feel like even watching her
stories the past few days she was trying
to like induce
labor i feel like that i've been
watching a lot of that apparently like
spicy food
induces labor because also um lauren
lindyke
is super pregnant and they're trying
like she might even have given birth at
this point well
if you ever would watch friends there's
an episode on rachel like literally the
baby won't come out of her
and the best thing to do you can try all
these different things like eating spicy
foods like herbal teas castor oil
but the really most effective way to
induce childbirth is having sex
so that was like a whole premise of an
episode because rachel and ross weren't
together but she wanted the baby out so
bad so she was like bigger most [ __ ]
and he was like no and then they finally
started to [ __ ] oh interesting came out
that makes sense because all these
instagramers who are like showing how
they induce labor aren't gonna like show
us them having sex
yeah that's too bad but
by the way
you know what i really like it came to
me and you guys everybody wanted us to
talk slower
yeah yeah what do you really like
i really i like how she had the baby and
posted it on instagram and like that's
it like people with these like
you know announcements did she didn't
she no like literally laura was off
instagram for 12 hours why oh she had a
baby here's a picture of all three of
them yep
like sometimes like simplest
sometimes simplicity is so simple and
perfect
i agree and this is some beautiful news
i really love the name reminds me
obviously of yellowstone
i'm not sure like so i was a source
and they like love yellowstone i heard
so i actually think
it might have been which is cute which
is cute
that's like you naming your child brie
from desperate housewives
yeah it's not as iconic as like no not
at all but it's yellowstone
but it's referencing dutton because like
dutton is everything and i'm sure they
could get so much cool
merch from like the show that's really
cool oh wait is done the family's like
family's last name john dutton beth
dutton yeah that sounds familiar
jamie that beth dutton was a real pain
in the ass those few episodes i watched
i know but
you have that's why you have to power
through it girl you're rich smile once
in a while
that's why you have to power through
because she's everything of the sort is
she
yeah i did not get eots no i know
because like
it's called character development
speaking of character development and
amazing show ideas
ted the series adaptation is set at
peacock from seth macfarlane
i feel like this is a personal gift i
feel like nobody cares about this but uh
from peacock to us yeah and i need other
people to start like caring
yeah no i think that people do care
everybody loves ted
a lie that just everybody loves ted one
it just doesn't get talked about enough
no people like ted two more than we do
i thought ted two was hysterical i just
don't like the premise of ted two
because there's no reason why
um mark wahlberg and mila kunis should
have broken up they were otp
agreed to get back together at the end
of movie two of tattoo
yeah no she's not even afraid they just
she wasn't in it and i got amanda's
seafood that was so weird
it just doesn't make sense to me so i
can't get on board yeah because they
really were like otp and it shouldn't
have even been about them in the second
movie like that was like a really random
plot twist and unnecessary one yeah
like if you couldn't get her to do the
movie then maybe every time she's on a
work trip the whole time or something
but don't have mark fall in love with
someone else right
anyways a live action series adaptation
live action
of oh right wait so live action like
it'll be will we get a real
bear yeah right no i think it's still a
teddy bear like because even though this
is the movie
live action yes we have real people
you know one time i met the real ted i
know and why didn't you kidnap him like
that guy
i think we're alone now i don't know i
really should have but
it's in my friend's bedroom the og ted
it was gifted to seth mcfarlane
from seth mcmurlin and honestly i've
never been so jealous like i've never
coveted
i don't really like look at other people
and actually that's a lie but i'm
jealous of a lot of people like
everything they have
but this ted died
it was the coolest thing i've ever seen
that would to me be like a celebrity i
would
love to meet no and i actually can't
think about ted for too long cause then
i remember that
ted doesn't exist it's like a fictional
character and like that makes me really
upset but then it makes me happy to know
that he exists in seth macfarlane's
brain
yeah and that there's someone out there
just creating such hysterical stuff
steph mcfarland is really like a
talent i feel like we talk about him
every once in a while on the tours he
reminds me of elon musk a little bit
jackie 100 i feel like they would get
along
similar energy and they kind of look
alike i also think they're both
geniuses in their own respective fields
yeah that's such a good call i think
they should become friends
i think they should too i feel like we
should watch that other set mcfarland
show
the one on the spaceship the orwell or
vorville
yeah um okay but i actually heard it's
really good i don't know why we don't
watch it
but what we want i don't know why you
[ __ ] read this i know goddamn sorry
it's on the sci-fi network like i don't
even think i have that channel yeah
that's true a live-action
series adaptation of the ted movies has
been ordered straight to series that
peacock variety has learned
seth macfarlane is currently in
negotiations to reprise the voice role
of
a foul-mouthed pot-smoking teddy bear
brought to life by the magic of a little
boy's wish
oh my god by the way and i think in the
story that i read
there's no confirmation about whether
mark wahlberg will be involved at all
and honestly like i don't need him like
i need a ted reality show
i need a ted docu-series i just need ted
i just need jeff mcfarlane and the bear
i totally agree like ted on his own like
ted goes on like a spiritual journey
whatever it is
right i just need ted travels first
class ted travels coach
ted talk yeah like i just need oh i'm so
excited
i haven't like heard much of anything
that has made me excited for peacock
except for that housewives all-stars
thing
but this is a big notch in the peacock
belt
yes definitely or you don't even know if
i have peacock
you do that's where you watch um
stuff you have peacock for sure because
you were always saying like
you had like if you ever watch old bravo
shows you did that one weekend yeah i
watched it i see prep
yeah that's where you he loves it
speaking of
nyc prep actually that's a perfect segue
into our next story brought to you by
bowling branch
yep bowlin branch knows high quality
sleep doesn't stop at your mattress
their ultra soft organic sheets are
transparently sourced and produced in
safe
fair conditions you'll you'll feel a
difference
you'll cough in your sheets that's how
good they are you'll feel a difference
and know you're making one
bowling branch started with a mission
produced the highest quality sheets on
the market and make the world
a better place in the process today
they're still the best choice for anyone
who wants comfort that lasts
very true i can vouch for bowling branch
first of all stunning linens like
cooling light feathery soft great price
look great feel great and they help the
environment you know who loves
bowling brands she so much t-h-o t-h-e-o
he sleeps in them
every single night and he sleeps like
the king that he is so the sheets that i
have are the signature hem sheets
they're the best sellers for really good
reason they get softer with every wash
they're lightweight and it's 100 organic
cotton sateen weave
that's perfect for all seasons um
bowling branch partners with family
owned businesses
that align with the same values and
standards as them and they are pledging
to double us
assembly jobs this year to experience
the best sheets you've ever felt choose
bowling branch
you can try them worry free for 30
nights with free shipping and returns
and our listeners can get exclusive 15
off with your first set of sheets
with promo code toast bowlin branch dot
com that's b-o-l-l
a-n-d branch dot com promo code toast
love it thank you for that interlude
next up the gossip girl trailer reveals
a new threat to elite
new york city students okay a trailer
for the racy hbo max gossip girl reboot
sees the elite students at manhattan's
constant billard school for girls in st
jude's school for boys targeted by a
mysterious stalker
this time through social media did you
miss me i know i've missed you the
narrator voiced by kristen bell
says several yes again says several of
the new casts here at their phones then
they are then warned by a teacher about
gossip girl an anonymous instagram
account
that spies on our students is it girl
with a secret
it's girl with a secret okay i watch the
trailer i just want to say my overall
impression was that it looks
very good very gen z like very
of the times of what the high school
kids are doing now
okay i have to say when i heard about
this reboot i thought it was the
luxurious thing ever like let sleeping
[ __ ] dogs lie like
write your own show after the trailer i
was like this show's amazing it looks so
good
it looks very very good my only concern
after reading this story is like okay so
gossip girl is kristen bell
again with the same voice and that
actually makes it nice for continuity
but that would mean that like gossip
girls now what like well first of all
gossip girl stan humphrey
yeah well spoiler alert and she would be
about 35 now like spying on high school
students
predator predator gossip girl's a
predator they should have
actually for the sake of this making
sense and not being beyond creepy
they should have gotten a new voice no
honestly because at the end of the day
in the gossip girls series like the
voice didn't even matter because the
voice was a woman and gossip girl was a
man like
it's so stupid so the voice didn't even
matter it was just like a like a
narration tool
yeah but like this but yeah it's not
like i thought the girl was sending
voicemails to people with that voice
it's just for the show like i understand
but it's
it is it seems weird to me that this
same person that was like
coming for blair is now coming for these
new kids like it's obviously a person
it's a 40 year old man in his basement
it's not the same person i'm hungry
it's not the same person it's not the
same person it's good for the economy
gossip girl is good for the economy um
also
i feel like a job that i wish i got was
the voice of a gossip girl i read
somewhere that like your vocal fry is
just
off the charts for that i'm so hurt
oh my god like no offense hit me where
it hurts my
voice watch this what are you saying
give me a gossip girl script and we're
going to have a girl off this is what
you're going to say okay you're going to
say did you miss me
i know i've missed you that's it oh go
anyway
every time you're damien thank you
did you miss me i know i've missed you
okay let me clear my throat and then
you're doing it next and we're gonna see
who's better
i never said i wanted the job but okay
and i never said i didn't also have
vocal fry but okay what is it
did you
okay i'm nervous okay
okay did you me
amazing she got the part let me do it
did you miss me i know i've missed you
that was pretty good it was a little
louie on camera let me try it again
you started strong oh you liked the
beginning i liked it you missed you
did you miss me i know i've missed you i
i
i felt the cabaret coming out of me yeah
you go
okay it's not gonna actually make a
difference in yourself
wwd what would dan humphrey do
well okay i'm just gonna go for it i'm
gonna rip off the van okay it's
very intimidating you did this to us
no i know but i feel like i'm better off
for it so go
okay i just okay
did you miss me i know i've missed you
[ __ ] that was really good
i think who do you think gets the job i
think jackie probably
let me just do one more time okay
yeah i don't like that line okay hey add
hey there upper east siders
did you miss me i know i've missed you
hey there upper eastsiders did you miss
me i know i missed you
that's pretty good that was that was a
good hay there sick that was good
do you have to go where can we move on
yet oh i'm having fun but if you're not
i you know i hate being put on the spot
literally okay
wwk md what would kim possible do
kpd it's hey there upper east side
yeah hey there upper east siders did you
miss me
i know i missed you i don't know why i'm
doing facial expressions like yeah like
people like this
yeah okay okay that was good okay we
need to move on chris and mel got the
part you and i did not
very sad so sad are you gonna watch what
do you think overall thoughts i mean
like there's so many things i'm gonna
watch that i don't end up watching so am
i
running the second this drops at
midnight pacific time no
uh if i get bored enough i'll probably
watch it i like watching shows that are
filmed in new york i'm always like oh
i've been there
i stood on that corner it just makes
them interesting and fun so if it's
if it's popping off and people are like
talking about it i'll probably watch it
i think i'm going to wind up watching
and i think it's going to pop
off based on this trailer also thomas
doherty is in it he's from
descendants and i'm not sure if they're
still dating but he was
dove cameron that's doug cameron's man
he actually seems like perfect for the
show
he's very like chuck bass energy i
literally read an article
yesterday about dove cameron talking
about her ex-fiance
is that this guy oh no she was engaged
like
when she was very young before thomas
got it and i i
never heard that her and thomas broke up
okay but i do need to consult with the
snitch and find out she's
our dove cameron correspondent she is
dcc
anyways i'm glad he got another role and
he seems to blend perfectly with the
cast the cast of
stunning people yeah i think it's going
to be really good i'm feeling optimistic
me too
next up a little more in what the kids
are up to news
and claudia is going to have to explain
some of it austin mcbroom
and bryce hall will fight in miami
drawing influencers in droves
now it's time for the social media stars
to run amok in miami we're told people
are already starting to arrive for a
bizarre event that will see
tick-tock stars fist fighting with
youtubers
organizers are expecting a slew of
influencers with more than a billion
followers between them
at the hard rock hotel for the social
gloves battle of the platforms boxing
tournaments
on saturday nights that's what it's
officially being called social gloves
battle of the platform so i guess it's
tick tock versus youtube
which one's the talker bryce hall i
believe is the
uh talker and also mcbroom is the
youtuber and honestly this is
so unbelievably illusory like the fact
that addison ray
is directly linked to this person who's
participating in this tomfoolery of a
circus
and she also is friends with kourtney
kardashian and has been on keeping up
like
that's unacceptable behavior addison and
bryce still together no
oh okay that's good but they're
expecting people who are expected to go
to the
to the fight trey songz charlie and
dixie demilio
adam ross julia rose chelsea briggs
jeffrey starr
lil yachty chase hudson is that little
hottie lahuda
noah beck and jordan jones
what the heck i i understand why you
think this is illusory but
this isn't a new trend where like
because there's not a lot of
entertainment right now like people are
just
fighting like for for views
yeah no i think this is like people
taking after jake paul and logan paul
thinking that like that's in their
future
but i just like they've been doing a lot
of press around this there was a press
conference and of course like they got
into a fight
austin and bryce and like bryce hall is
like the definition
truly at his core if you look up in the
dictionary the word
loser you will find a picture of bryce
hall he's such a loser
and i can't wait for him to lose and
i'm team austin mcbroom you are
we team bryce out here even the
propriety team bryce on god
that is this trend you have to watch
this video tana went to the press
conference you have to send it to me
okay tana mojo went to the press
conference
and after the press conference she was
like being paparazzi outside
and they were asking her like what she
thought of the fight in the press
conference and she just like responded
so weird and people were like why are
you talking like that
and it's become a trend on tick tock tip
imitate it it kind of changed all of her
bios even the paparazzi team bryce on
god
she goes like this you're you're the is
this when she was wearing the fendi
outfit
no she was wearing also the outfit's
weird too so like when people are
recreating it
she's wearing a shirt it's like a crop
top knit shirt that also comes with like
a little glove knit
it's so bizarre sounds so cute so
everyone on tick tock is like putting
socks on their arms to like pretend to
be her glasses that's funny and so she's
like
we seen bryce out here even the
paparazzi team bryce on god and then she
turns around and like
the way she's talking is so weird it's
my i've been saying it
every time and she's talking about this
fight even the paparazzi team bryce yeah
but you're not no no no no even though i
love tick tock
so like battle of the platforms i can't
believe we're talking about this it's so
illusory
battle the platforms like i choose
tick-tock but battle of these two people
i choose the the smaller loser
very cool got it well there's also
supposed to be performances by dj khaled
migos and little baby
dj khaled has to stop
all of it he can't stop honestly
honestly as a platform snapchat
should be taken down from the app store
just because of the monster they made
out of tj khaled like
i'm kind of like over him and his like
[ __ ] chaotic energy and his
toxicity i like his energy i don't
oh i'm sorry so i guess you won't be
watching oh i will definitely be
watching
i want to watch i kind of like these
these two these
gatherings and get-togethers it brings
people together like
i'm not even into the sport per se i'm
not even into these people but like
just to you know see the people in the
crowds like i'm here for it there's not
that much else going on right now no i
agree
i've actually since watching that logan
paul fight and then i watched the jake
one before like i
love it it's like everyone's watching
the same thing
yeah which is what you know we love
which is what we're craving yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's going to lead into our tv
recap
it's the final story oh
give us like a stripped down version
[Music]
you're like a possessed music teacher
ned schneider like not mentioning
because his energy is like the
the intense one you're like the music
teacher yeah he's very in touch with her
feelings
i think that if life worked out
differently for me i would teach music
like to like annoying kids yeah and you
would be like
very in touch with your feelings and
also like very brutally honest
yeah and also in charge of the spring
musical you would be in charge of the
spring music i just want to let you know
i'm hanging on by a thread okay so maybe
it's time to get into the fifth and
final
i'm just letting you know like i might
need to lay down to my left briefly
but well no if you need to lay down put
your head so where your mic is still
there so you can still talk
a good idea yeah just yeah you have four
you have four pillows so maybe you could
use one for your head
yeah okay fifth and final story kanye
has unfollowed
kanye has unfollowed kim and her sisters
on twitter
i saw this i'm so sad kanye is no longer
keeping up with the kardashians
the rapper recently unfollowed his
estranged wife kim and all of her
sisters on twitter
though it's unclear if he made the move
before or after all of their birthday
tributes to him earlier this week like
doesn't someone track this stuff
can't we find out but does he still
follow her on instagram she's the only
person
wes still follows only one person on
instagram and that's kim
the mother of his children i'm so sad
like i just want to
quickly check kanye's twitter and just
make sure he still follows people
you know right like he didn't go from
300 to zero and including his sister or
did he just go from 300 to 290.
okay he follows 218. okay so that's
pretty um that's
pretty intentional pretty pretty
intentionally pretty intentional okay
let's talk about keeping up with the
kardashians is there something
that you need to say before we do oh
there is thank you for reminding me hold
on
there's something i need to say actually
and that is that this
segment is brought to you by noom think
about everything you've ever learned
about getting healthy there's a lot of
contradictory information out there
and things like that old-fashioned food
pyramid aren't much health
i know about that enter noon noom
is a lifestyle app it is the first and
last place you need to go if you are
looking to make a change in your life i
absolutely love noon because it gives me
information that i need
and also helps me stay consistent
accountable
and just in charge of my own destiny and
my goals it's not about what you just
ate but about how you eat in general
noom teaches you about your eating your
cravings and how to build new habits so
you can ditch
ditch your misconceptions and get smart
about food and the choices
that you make numa is based in
psychology and it teaches you why you
make the choices that you do
and it gives you the tools to replace
your habits with healthier ones
noom's cognitive behavioral approach
means you're not just losing weight
you're building the habits you need to
keep it off that is so
important for any journey that you're on
it's not just about doing this or that
it's about
building healthier habits for a
healthier lifestyle over 80 percent of
numerous finish the program and over 60
percent have stuck with their goals for
at least one year
okay numerous we love that okay
there's a science to getting healthier
it's called noom sign up for your trial
today at nooman.com
learn how to eat again with noom sign up
for your trial today
at noon n-o-o-m dot com slash
toast are you ready to learn how to live
healthier sign up for noom today
at noom
i also realized when i was laying down
that everyone could see my pimple so i
had to readjust
oh damn that's a real deandre's choice
to sit up or to expose your pimple i
think
oh man i'm learning how to throw to
throw up
so keeping with the kardashians i'm like
really surprised that you didn't like it
because i thought it was such a nice
episode like
first of all if i don't find out what
these things are
if i don't find out what these things
are do you know what i'm talking about
yeah courtney's things that need to
happen in order for her to get her and
scott to get back together
what are these things i hate speaking in
such vague terms like just say it what
are the things
what do you think let's say what do you
think the things are i feel like it has
to do with his sobriety
yeah maybe it needs to get down to zero
drug
and alcohol usage fully sober well
scott is probably california sober yes
no i'm sure that scott drinks alcohol
like i don't think he's drinking in the
way that he used to but i think for
courtney
she needs zero yeah
he can't commit to that lifestyle but
maybe he's just waiting to get to a
place in his life like where he can and
then he'll finally be with courtney but
like maybe
she might fall in love before that with
you which it seems like she has i don't
think they're meant to be together i
really really don't i was like i never
really feel them as a couple and
honestly i hate that storyline like get
something new to talk about
but last night i was kind of like just
give it a chance you know what when she
put her smooth shirt in the time capsule
i was wishing that she named her
website smooch instead of pooch that's a
really good i think that would have been
really cute and like a cute homage to
like where she started and i love when
i actually really liked her little bit
and she was like
i'll never forget like where i came from
and i thought it was really nice
i liked it too and also um
she folded that shirt really well she
did fold that chart really well
um the other monumental things in the
episode were that chloe apparently moved
to boston but like did that ever happen
i think she moved for the season they
made me really want to go to zuma i
passed it this morning and i was like
damn i'm hungry
i went to zuma like a few times and
every time i hated it like really
it's like a faux boo it is but what's
not to like like it's just bad
oh i think it's good oh i i would like
when i passed zuma they had all these
like
signs in the window saying that like you
can order they're delivering like that
right
that might be my lunch today oh that
sounds nice yeah thanks chloe's
influence so i guess
she did move to boston i don't remember
her ever living there in this list last
year
well i mean i feel like their content
isn't you know
she's not like in the moment posting
everything like i just feel like we
would know if chloe was living in boston
well this
should be public the season's ending now
are the celtics in the playoffs
i haven't seen them in my journey i
haven't heard about them
like i don't think background exact
sports shows i don't think that they are
okay cool so hopefully they're back in
l.a i'm glad they got the deeds back to
their house
yes we got that story line and then like
oh we got the dudes back like
yeah how yeah they are in the playoffs
so chloe's still in boston well or
wherever the hell they're playing
yeah um the trip was really nice
i actually think the idea of the time
capsule was sweet and i liked that game
that they played
um where they had to act out like random
scenes from agreed
i thought it was cute i just like kind
of realized
first of all like and i think we've all
known this like kendall gives me nothing
like literally nothing and i think last
night's episode was probably the hardest
she's ever tried to give
something um in the last couple years
and i think she gave less than normal
like
she's so blah yeah and it's like thank
god she's like the most stunning woman
in the world because
she's so boring yeah when her and kylie
were having that conversation when they
were exchanging gifts
i was like they both sorry love kylie
boring yeah boring it was it was boring
i'm glad that they at least tried though
like that was something would have
been nice to see rob i didn't realize it
was gone until chloe said everyone but
rob was here i was like oh right
oh rob yeah yeah did you also see like a
page six article they gifted like the
crew that's been with them
since they won like over three hundred
thousand dollars worth of rolexes oh no
i didn't see that that's
so nice the group hugs at the end and
the fireworks were really sweet
yeah no but you know what they drop they
dragged it out so much that i'm actually
glad it's over
yeah what's that phrase
don't be sad it's over smile that it
happened
and i'm smiling yeah i did like how when
they were doing the time capsule they
had side by sides like very
real housewives finale side by sides of
like where they started on the show and
where they ended
what i wanted to see was i wanted to see
a side by side of their first
confessional look versus their last one
that's a good call because that would
have been really telling
yeah of course how they look but also
the backgrounds and the like where
the jewelry the styling i wish that
that's what we saw not even like
just the confessionals because you know
i'm sure episode one they went to their
confessionals looking and feeling their
best
i also think that they should
i should have went to dash at some point
this season yeah
i forgot about dash and i really forgot
about smooch
yeah me too they should go back they
should go back
honestly so crazy i think what i learned
from last night's episode and i i had a
little bit of an inkling
about this but i think that chris
is the best jenner slash kardashian i
think a lot of people feel that way why
what did she do that made you feel that
way
she just like makes you laugh and then
she also makes you cry like she's
so funny she gives it all she's at the
show she really does she really really
and she's like in such a stable
relationship i'm obsessed with corey
gamble like i literally want to steal
him from chris if i weren't so happy for
them
yeah and i just feel like it's not
really spoken about enough how kris
jenner
is the best one like i feel like
recently it is spoken about like
everyone it's like who's your favorite
kardashian people are like chris i
really do feel like she's gotten her
like i feel her start following like
chris jenner paparazzi accounts like i'm
like
obsessed with her look and like her
whole life like when i grow up i
literally want to be chris jenner no
it's it's amazing like what she's
created and like the family and what
she's been through
yeah people forget she is oh gee
hollywood nicole brown
simpson g-o-j she is o-g-o-j
did she testify i don't know she did
something i can't remember from the
american from the show yeah yeah
whatever she was like an interworld part
she was really good friends with nicole
brown simpson
and like she's just lived so many lives
and i'm just obsessed like that was my
that was your takeaway yeah yeah and so
the only other thing that was
interesting was kim and chris's
conversation wherein she did her best to
explain
why they are splitting up and she failed
the baby bar as predicted
by me and she failed the baby bar i was
really shocked about that like
oh my god do you think she's gonna like
she is actually she is studying again
because she's been posting stuff
um and she said the next test is in june
and we just started june
if she i hope really hope she passes but
like at what point are you like
i can't do you give up yeah i don't know
and it's not even the bar it's the baby
bar
no but the baby bar like makes it so
that you don't have to do
like that's the bar apparently it's
harder no no the baby bar
yeah because she's not in law school
she's in this internship
yeah you think yeah and i wonder how
many times you can fail it before like
you're not eligible anymore
because no offense like if i go
to jail and i get like a public defender
who failed the bar
11 times i think i'd just rather
represent myself
oh my god yeah you would yeah your honor
i think you please i didn't do anything
even if you had like a rock star lawyer
you'd still want to defend yourself no i
just i don't know how
the hardest part i mean i've never been
arraigned or anything but i imagine it's
difficult to hear all these people like
talking about you and things you did and
like you can't even respond
yeah for sure very upsetting so that's
that on that
it's our final keeping up with the
kardashians no reunion
oh reunion so
there's possibly two or three i'm so
excited for that i'm excited for hulu
i'm excited to get more deets and i'm
glad that this chapter's over i
personally really like change so i'm
excited to see what's next
i'm so excited about the reunion i
forgot i'm ready that just brightened my
whole day
you're welcome okay well that's all i
have to really contribute to society
today i'm sorry i wasn't my best but
i think we should just like at a glance
look at the wonderful week we've had i
feel like this is one of my most
productive weeks yeah we had so many
fabulous episodes
our episodes were just like literally
killing it in the charts like we're just
we're just killing it so i'm just
patting myself on the back great week
everyone great work
um enjoy your weekend reminder we're not
here on monday but there is a patreon
episode coming out so if you need a
podcast to listen to monday morning we
got you covered
we're back in studio on tuesday yes
that's so exciting three day weekend
for us and we hope you guys have an
amazing weekend thank you so much for
listening to
our show the millennial morning show
where we go live
not anymore we used to go live and now
we don't go live
but okay thank you so much for watching
in the morning through friday
around roughly 10 30 eastern time
depends on the day
we are on the youtube the podcast tab
spotify stitcher i heart radio public
radio i love
radio places and in all of those places
i'm sure you are capable of leaving a
review of some sort so please leave us
a five star review if you genuinely
enjoy the show and it contributes
to a positive moment in your day we
would love to hear from you
if you have positive feedback to share
and if you don't you can quietly shut
the [ __ ] up
it's just if you have nothing nice to
say then don't say anything at all it's
a very
simple simple policy so
that's all you have nothing nice to say
join a former toaster facebook group
if you have something nice to say you're
not alone
if you have nothing nice to say honestly
i kind of understand no
stop if you have nothing nice to say
then like that's really funny but then
seriously like go [ __ ]
phone okay seriously like i hate you
okay
you're disgusting and crusty if you have
nothing nice to say then why did you
watch for this long in the episode
yeah if you're here i think you actually
have a nice thing to say so maybe we
shouldn't harp we shouldn't harp if you
have something nice to say go tell
someone something nice okay
what like just wrap it up
okay okay goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye